this is about Microsoft translator app
which is Microsoft's solution for
self-service customization with a unique
twist involving your crowd let me give
you a 30 minute discourse hear a lecture
on on machine translation technology and
what constitutes quality so there are
only two ingredients that affect a
machine translation quality let's the
engine and that's the training data that
you're using to produce statistical
models that help you produce these
translations so of course you need to
have a decent engine but the major
driver is the data that you feed to that
engine to learn from what is relevant
here is to look at what are the sources
of data of course you can use your most
important to parallel documents
translation memory for instance that you
already have but even more so the
customization to specific domains we
have heard that a lot today the
domain-specific customization and we are
true believer in it and we have the data
to prove it it helps you really produce
a better engine than if you don't do
that all right so wouldn't it be great
if you can use a variety of sources to
collect their parallel data because it
is so important within your domain
wouldn't it be great if you can use your
website your application to help you
collect the data from your users from
your community from your vendors we've
heard about that a little bit already
today and in addition use your
translation memory and other sources of
the Pearl documents that you already
have it wouldn't be great if you could
feed that all to a central system and
produce a customized engine out of it in
addition of course you want to use all
of that all of that data directly as
you're doing translations right you well
what you already have human translated
you wanted transparently and in real
time reuse as you're performing
translations on your site orbit in your
application one of the application I
want to talk about here is the microsoft
knowledge base Microsoft's really
showcase of all of the stuff that my
team produces Martine will talk about it
in her talk a little bit later today
and give you more details what I'm
talking about years that is the is the
technology here you see the Arabic
automatic translated knowledgebase
article and the UI on top of it that
allows anybody and user and evander any
employee to provide suggestions of
course our vendor or employee can
approve or reject the people who are
allowed to make authoritative
translations and review all of it and
they can this is the the user interface
of the self-service customization
immediately reuse their data to train
their cust their custom empty engine and
use it for the real-time translation as
the as the side grows and develops thank
you very much